[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den heute
Nachrichten Tag 6 des russischen
Angriffs auf die Ukraine im Osten ist
die Hafenstadt mariopol die eine halbe
Million Einwohner hat nach einer
russischen Offensive ohne Strom das
erklärte der Gouverneur der Region die
russische Armee rückt derzeit sowohl von
der Krim als auch von der russischen
Grenze auf die Stadt zu gleichzeitig
Rollen immer mehr russische
panzerrichtung Kiew und fliegen Raketen
auch auf andere Städte
russische Raketen schlagen mitten im
Zentrum von rakif ein der zweitgrößten
Stadt das Landes die Zerstörung ist
riesig
das ist mein Auto das ganze hier kannst
du dir nicht ansehen ohne zu weinen sagt
dieser Ukrainer der die Zähne filmt
Bombeneinschläge in der ganzen Stadt die
Verteidigung stehe aber weiter so der
Leiter der Regionalverwaltung vor Ort
der ukrainische Präsident fordert
unterdessen eine weltweite
Flugverbotszone für Russland
die internationale Gemeinschaft muss
eine vollständige Sperrung des Luftraums
für russische Raketen Flugzeuge und
Hubschrauber erwägen wir müssen diesen
Staat den Zugang zu allen Häfen allen
Kanälen und allen Flughäfen dieser Welt
verwehren
Fliegeralarm in Kiew heute morgen
wiederholen die Sirenen wieder fallen
Bomben die Hauptstadt ist wohl noch in
ukrainischer Hand doch die Frage ist wie
lange noch diese Satellitenbilder zeigen
den Vormarsch der russischen Truppen auf
Kiew ein Militärkonvoi aus Panzern und
Armeefahrzeugen mehr als 60 Kilometer
lang scheinbar unaufhaltsam rollt er
immer weiter Richtung Hauptstadt auch in
der Nacht gingen die Kämpfe weiter eine
Militärbasis nahe Kiew soll schwer
getroffen worden sein hier schlugen
offenbar gleich mehrere russische
Raketen ein
sie haben auch eine vakuumbombe
eingesetzt die von der Genfer Konvention
verboten ist die Zerstörung die Russland
uns zufügen will ist sehr groß aber die
Ukrainer werden Widerstand leisten wir
verteidigen unsere Heimat wir haben
keine andere Wahl es ist Tag 6 der
russischen Invasion der ukrainische
Widerstand ist ungebrochen die Kämpfe
gehen weiter
[Musik]
in Moskau wird den Menschen in Russland
angesichts dieser Bilder immer klarer
dass es kein Friedenseinsatz ist und
werden die Sanktionen des Westens immer
spürbarer
ja diese Bilder werden hier so nicht
gezeigt und eine knappe Mehrheit der
russischen Bevölkerung dürfte der
russischen Propaganda folgen und die
sagt und zeigt eben dass zivile Ziele
nicht beschossen werden nur militärische
und im Gegenteil es sei die Ukraine die
menschliche Schutzschilder benutze und
ja die Sanktionen zeigen Wirkung
insbesondere bei den mächtigsten und
möglicherweise hat das jetzt auch einige
Oligarchen dazu geführt sich öffentlich
gegen den Krieg auszusprechen gestern
Abend hatte ein Medienmogul einen
offenen Brief an Putin verfasst dort
schreibt der Präsident Putin bitte
stoppen Sie diesen Krieg ob diese
Distanzierung der wichtigen Elite nun
Druck auf Putin ausüben kann das bleibt
allerdings abzuwarten
vielen Dank Anna Feist in Moskau
Katrin Eigendorf ist in der Ukraine wir
haben die unendliche Kolonne von
russischen Panzern gesehen Kathrin die
offenbar auf Kiew zurollen gleichzeitig
Raketen überall wie beunruhigt sind die
Menschen
an diesem sechsten Tag des Krieges
wächst wirklich die Unruhe sehr denn
alle haben mittlerweile verstanden dass
Putin noch einmal ganz klar diesen Krieg
eskalieren will es hat Friedensgespräche
gegeben während die Gespräche gelaufen
sind wurde die zweitgrößte Stadt der
Ukraine schwer bombardiert wir hören
auch heute wieder aus hackiv dass dort
mittlerweile Bomben in der Innenstadt
eingehen dass man ganz klar auf zivile
auf Zivilisten zielt das ist auch der
Fall in Kiew und das beunruhigt die
Menschen natürlich sehr wir sehen hier
in den sozialen Medien und auch bei
unseren Gesprächspartner mit dem wir in
Kontakt sind das mittlerweile auch
wirklich die Verzweiflung wächst einfach
zu sehen dass Freunde dass man Freunde
dass man auch im Prinzip bekannte
Piloten das wird jetzt gerade im Netz
geteilt verliert dass es hier immer mehr
Opfer gibt die ukrainische Bevölkerung
richtet sich darauf ein dass dieser
Krieg jetzt mit aller Brutalität
weitergeführt wird und das macht den
Menschen natürlich große große Sorge
vielen Dank Katrin Eigendorf in der
Ukraine für diese Eindrücke
allein gestern haben 100.000 Flüchtlinge
die ukrainische Grenze nach Polen
überquert so die polnischen
Grenzschützer insgesamt sind seit Beginn
des Kriegs fast
380.000 Menschen aus der Ukraine
gekommen die langen Schlange der
vergangenen Tage haben sich verkürzt
weil Frauen und Kinder jetzt praktisch
ohne Kontrolle einfach durchgelassen
werden die Erleichterung bei ihnen groß
aber auch die Sorge über das was in der
Heimat passiert
es ist ihre erste Station raus aus dem
Krieg tausende kommen an am Grenzbahnhof
von chemische in Polen darauf haben die
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge hingefiebert
die Angst dass etwas passiert auf
ukrainischer Seite war immer dabei und
wenn das überhaupt geht sie wird größer
Angst große Angst es ist wahrscheinlich
das Atomwaffen eingesetzt werden das ist
die größte Angst jetzt
wer mit dem zukommt ist erschöpft wer zu
Fuß über die Grenze nach mittelka kommt
ist am Ende seiner Kräfte
stundenlanges Warten auf ukrainischer
Seite haben sie hinter sich bevor sie es
nach Polen schaffen
mein Mann hat uns zur Grenze gebracht
und ist in die Ukraine zurückgekehrt er
ist zurückgekehrt und kämpft in der
Freiwilligen Armee um unsere Stadt zu
verteidigen
kommen jetzt nach chemiesta für Menschen
die keine Verwandten haben die sie
abholen haben die Polen Auffanglager
eingerichtet auch viele Ausländer sind
aus der Ukraine geflohen tausende junger
Leute studieren dort
und Navi wir haben die Raketen gesehen
und gefühlt ich wohne im Zentrum von
Odessa ich hatte Angst natürlich am
gleichen Tag habe ich mich entschieden
die Stadt zu verlassen
Zwischenstation polnisches Grenzgebiet
wer mit dem Zug weiter will muss nicht
bezahlen die Rückkehr in die Heimat
allerdings rückt mit jedem Tag in
weitere Ferne
und wenn sie den Menschen in der Ukraine
helfen wollen können Sie spenden zum
Beispiel beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Ukraine IBAN de65
100-400-100 400 alle Infos auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text auf
Seite 890
in diesem Minuten kommt das Europäische
Parlament zusammen Sondersitzung zum
Krieg in der Ukraine zusammen mit
kommissionschefin von der Leyen
diskutieren die Abgeordneten über den
russischen Einmarsch in der Ukraine und
das Vorgehen der EU anschließend wollen
die Parlamentarier eine Resolution
verabschieden einer gelinek in Brüssel
wie soll sie denn aussehen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski will
sich zu Beginn der Debatte ins
Europaparlament schalten lassen wenn das
denn technisch klappt und er wird seinen
Wunsch dass sein Land der Ukraine
beitreten will noch mal bekräftigen er
hatte ja gestern Abend schon den
entsprechenden Brief dazu geschrieben
und abgeschickt die parlamentare die
Parlamentarier debattieren nun eine
Resolution in der die Ukraine
tatsächlich den
beitrittskandidatenstatus bekommen soll
das ist eine weitgehend symbolische
Geste aber man will natürlich in dieser
Situation der Ukraine nicht die Tür vor
der Nase zuschlagen die Abgeordneten
werden also die EU-Kommission und die
Mitgliedstaaten auffordern
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
aufzunehmen wohl wissend dass solche
Verhandlungen bei denen es darum geht
Standards europäische Standards bei der
Justiz bei der Gesetzgebung zu
übernehmen dass solche Verhandlungen
Jahre dauern können also hier geht es
eher um eine symbolische Geste der
Unterstützung des Europaparlaments für
die Ukraine vielen Dank Anna gelinek in
Brüssel
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof in
Den Haag will wegen Kriegsverbrechen und
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit in
der Ukraine ermitteln das Land hat vor
dem höchsten un-gericht außerdem Klage
wegen Völkermordes gegen Russland
beantragt untersucht werden sollen nicht
nur die aktuellen Kriegshandlungen
Russlands sondern auch die Konflikte in
der Ostukraine seit 2013
auf der Suche nach einer diplomatischen
Lösung ist bundesaußenministerin
baerbock erneut auf Reisen europäische
Einigkeit zu einer sei zu einer
Überlebensfrage geworden so bärbock am
Vormittag traf sie den französischen
sowie den polnischen Außenminister in
Lodz nun ist sie auf dem Weg nach New
York wo sie am Abend vor der
UN-Vollversammlung sprechen wird
die Türkei verweigert Kriegsschiffen die
Durchfahrt durch zwei mehr engen den
Bosporus und die da danellen die das
Schwarze Meer mit der Ägäis verbinden
ausgenommen sind Schiffe die zu ihren
Heimathäfen im Schwarzen Meer
zurückkehren auch russische Präsident
Erdogan erklärte sein Land werde weder
die Beziehungen zu Russland aufgeben
noch die zur Ukraine ein internationaler
Vertrag von 1936 erlaubt es der Türkei
in Kriegszeiten die mehr engen zu
schließen
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat auch in
Deutschland ganz unmittelbare Folgen die
Inflation geht nicht wie erhofft wieder
zurück in Bayern oder
Nordrhein-Westfalen etwa die am
Vormittag schon ihre Zahlen
veröffentlicht haben stiegen die Preise
zuletzt um
5,3%. die für den Nachmittag erwarteten
bundesweiten Zahlen dürften ähnlich hoch
liegen steigende Preise das trifft
natürlich nicht nur Verbraucher sondern
auch Betriebe
Theo Baumstark schaut nach den
Heizkörpern in seiner Wiesbadener
Sanitärfirma merken Sie die Inflation
daran besonders im Einkauf zahlt der
Unternehmer mittlerweile 50% mehr Stahl
Kupfer Energie fast alles ist in den
vergangenen Monaten teurer geworden und
das heißt auch die Kunden müssen mehr
zahlen die Kostensteigerung merkt man
natürlich bei Material vergessen darf
man auch die Spritkosten das heißt also
wir haben hier ungefähr 40 Wagen die
fahren jeden Tag werde ich die Stadt das
heißt jeder Tag kostet mindestens Moment
20 bis 30 Prozent mehr und Sprit das
muss man so sehen Theo Baumstark spürt
den haupttreiber der hohen Inflation
Energie im Januar waren die
Energieimporte über 144% teurer als im
Vorjahr das war noch vor dem Krieg in
der Ukraine die jüngste Eskalation sorgt
für neue Preissprünge bei Gas und Öl der
Preis für ein Barrel liegt erstmals seit
vielen Jahren wieder deutlich über 100
Dollar damit drohen auch viele andere
Verbraucherpreise weiter zu steigen
wir sehen an der aktuellen Situation
dass es von großem Nachteil ist und ein
hohes risikobjekt wenn man sich von
wenigen Lieferanten oder
Geschäftspartnern in eine große
Abhängigkeit begibt es unsicher
inwiefern die Lieferung überhaupt
aufrechterhalten werden können und
daraus erwächst natürlich ein Risiko für
die deutsche Wirtschaft insgesamt viele
hatten gehofft dass sich die Wirtschaft
nach dem corona-schock erholt der Krieg
in der Ukraine zeigt aber Deutschland
und Europa sind nicht nur politisch
betroffen die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
sind bisher kaum absehbar
schauen wir doch auf andere Themen
dieses Tages zunächst auf die
corona-zahlen die weiter sinken binnen
24 Stunden wohnen dem
Robert-Koch-Institut
122.11 Neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind
3.791 weniger als vor einer Woche
außerdem kamen 235 Todesfälle dazu die
sieben Tage Inzidenz liegt jetzt bei
ob Joghurtbecher oder Shampoo Flaschen
Tonnen von Plastikmüll landen Tag für
Tag dort wo sie nicht hingehören im Meer
die
un-umweltversammlung will nun bei ihrem
Treffen in Nairobi ein globales Abkommen
zum Schutz der Meere auf den Weg bringen
welche dramatischen Folgen der
Plastikmüll haben kann zeigt sich zum
Beispiel auf der Insel Lamo vor der
Küste Kenias
es ist ein Strand ohne Menschen und doch
liegen hier Tonnen von Plastikmüll
hunderte von Flip Flops Zahnbürsten
Flaschen die Strömung hat den Abfall
hierher getrieben Dreck aus aller Welt
ist hier vor der Küste Kenias angelandet
wir können es an einem Tag einsammeln
und am nächsten Tag wenn die Flut kommt
ist alles wieder da die Ozeane kennen
keine Grenzen und so bringen sie jeden
Tag mehr und mehr
die Welt erstickt im Plastikmüll das
sagt sich so leicht auf der kenianischen
Insel Lamy wird es greifbar die
Forscherin Karen Schuhe ist mit ihrem
Team in den Mangroven Wäldern unterwegs
sie wollen herausfinden wie viele und
welches Plastik hier ankommt überall
bedecken Tüten und Kanister den Boden
und verhindern so dass die Mangroven
Samen in der Erde keimen können
wenn unser Wal zerstört wird bedeutet
das dass der Gehalt an Kohlendioxid in
der Atmosphäre ansteigt und das führt
zur globalen Erwärmung und zum
Klimawandel
noch ist die Verschmutzung der Küste
Ostafrikas wenig erforscht auch weil
mittelknappt sind doch Wissenschaftler
wie Charles kostore und bei hartimajoma
wollen das ändern sie untersuchen
Wasserproben im Ozean nach mikroplastik
Forscher sagen uns das bis 2050 die
Menge an Plastik im Meer genauso groß
sein wird wie die an Fisch das versuchen
wir in unserer Region herauszufinden
eine Region in der viel zu viel Müll und
sachgemäß entsorgt wird doch auch viel
weniger Müll entsteht als im Rest der
Welt
ja extremen Regenfällen leidet der Osten
Australiens unter verheerenden
Überschwemmungen in Queensland und New
South Wales stehen ganze Landstriche
Meter hoch unter Wasser wäre Menschen
sind ums Leben gekommen zehntausende
sind auf der Flucht Australien ist seit
Jahren massiv von den Folgen des
Klimawandels betroffen
wir kommen noch zum Wetter bei uns die
Aussichten bis morgen Abend heute im
nordwestendichtewolken aber nur
vereinzelt Regen sonst freundlich mit
viel Sonne vier bis zehn Grad in der
Nacht im Nordwesten bewölkt sonst klar
oder nur locker bewölkt -10 bis +3 °c
die nächsten Nachrichten um 13 Uhr im
ZDF Mittagsmagazin aktuelle
Informationen gibt es jederzeit auf ZDF
heute und in unserer App hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit Babette von Kilian und
der Drehscheibe wir sehen uns um zwei
wieder tschüss und bis später
[Musik]